[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue à tous dans ce nouveau
débat consacré ce soir au vote
obligatoire
l'abstentionnisme tu le suffrage
universel c'est ce que scande plusieurs
acteurs de la vie politique
comment en effet considéré légitime le
résultat d'un vote qui auraient un taux
d'abstention très haut
rappelez-vous par exemple en l'an 2000
le référendum sur le passage au
quinquennat qui n'avait mobilisé que 30%
des votants alors que l'on se sente plus
ou moins concernés par une thématique
c'est compréhensible mais l'abstention
reste très forte pendant les élections
législatives et même les présidentielles
alors comment inciter les citoyens à
venir voter comment réconcilier les
français avec la politique
une solution pourrait être donc le vote
obligatoire avec nous pour en débattre
luc miserait conseiller municipal parti
communiste de trappes et david jutier
conseiller municipal europe ecologie les
verts de rambouillet bonsoir messieurs
bonsoir luc miserait un mot sur les
raisons de l'abstentionnisme pourquoi
s'abstiendront de voter aujourd'hui il
ya des raisons diverses
beaucoup de personnes ne voient plus
l'utilité du vote par déception il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui sont tellement
dans une situation économique et
financière déplorable que ils n'ont qui
ils sont dans la survie donc il le vote
est bien loin de leurs préoccupations
et donc par rapport à tout cela les
vraies réponses sont sur les enjeux
économiques et sociaux plus que nous
semble-t-il sur un vote obligatoire mais
on va y revenir
tout à fait enfin vous êtes pas
favorable en tout cas à ceux à ce vote
obligatoire
on n'est pas favorable parce qu'on on
pense que d'abord ça n'apportera pas
grand chose si ce n'est générer des
frustrations supplémentaires l'enjeu
c'est plutôt de d'attirer les gens à la
politique et contrairement à ce qui se
dit les gens s'intéressent à la
politique
pas parce qu'ils vont pas voter qui sont
pas intéressés c'est parce qu'il pense
qu'il n'y a pas de solution et dans ce
cadre là les politiques alternatives de
enfin plus exactement dans l'alternance
de la droite et du parti socialiste les
ont renforcés puisque aux solutions à
leurs problèmes personnels et collectifs
eh bien il n'y a pas eu grand chose en
tant que réponse positive et
constructive
david jutier alors les français
s'intéressent à la politique pourtant
vous pensez qu'il faut rendre le vote
obligatoire alors bonsoir bonsoir le
quiz rêve on sera toutes et à tous cette
question elle est un petit peu plus
complexe que faut-il le vote obligatoire
ou pas le vote obligatoire le vote
obligatoire je pense que c'est une
question à mettre au débat et que c'est
une opportunité justement pour discuter
tous ensemble des raisons de ce que vous
appelez l'abstention et je pense qu'on
peut l'appeler plus généralement même la
grève du vote pourquoi les personnes un
geste présentant parfois des points
allaient beaucoup de personnes
effectivement parce que beaucoup de gens
de françaises et de français ont
l'impression que leur vote a perdu son
sens et que leur vote ne sert à rien
n'est pas écouté donc on peut
effectivement débattre à partir de cette
proposition extrêmement clivante
extrêmement forte presque marketing du
devoir de vote de ces questions de
démocratie
il ya un point très important c'est que
si on introduit un nouveau devoir
aujourd'hui le vote est un droit en
france n'est pas un devoir
si on introduit un nouveau devoir
citoyen il faut également des droits
citoyens et des droits à la démocratie
qui devront forcément accompagné ce vote
obligatoire je pense que c'est une une
bonne porte d'entrée que d'amener ces
questions par le biais du du débat qu'on
devra avoir autour du vote obligatoire
puisque vous le rappeliez un vote pas
seulement sur les questions européennes
via un référendum qui on le sait attire
souvent assez peu mais les élections de
nos propres représentants souvent sont
des légitimes et je prendrai par exemple
les dernières élections départementales
dans le 78 on est dans l'est dans les
yvelines
lorsque vous avez presque 50 % de la
population deuxième tour qui ne va pas
voter c'était le cas sur le canton 2
de rambouillet vous ajoutez une dizaine
de pourcents qui ne sont pas inscrits
sur les listes électorales + 8 % de
votes blancs
les élus qui en sortent sont totalement
illégitime et je n'ai pas peur de le
dire
ça veut dire qu'il faut des droits
supplémentaires j'en ai deux principaux
qui me plaisent arrêtera d'esprit on va
on les développera ensuite la
proportionnelle à tous les niveaux
lorsque quelqu'un s'exprime son vote
doit se retrouver dans l'assemblée pour
laquelle il s'est il s'est prononcé
et puis la reconnaissance du vote blanc
un vrai des comptes est une vraie prise
en compte dans les résultats du vote
blanc si on oblige à un jour les
françaises et des français à se déplacer
au bureau de vote il faut que s'ils le
veulent voter blanc alors leur vote soit
réellement pris en compte et pas juste
compter dans les résultats
luc miserait des solutions pour inciter
lors des élections départementales avec
l opow qu'elle faisait allusion david
utile aux élections départementales et à
d'autres déjà
il ya quelque chose qui est sous-estimé
là on est en pleine campagne pour les
présidentielles et législatives
c'est
toutes les manipulations et tous les
mensonges qui peut y avoir c'est à dire
qu' il ya quelque chose qui m'a frappé
j'ai entendu un soi disant expert
expliqué que monsieur hamon parler de
trop loin et c'est ces mêmes experts qui
a ça que ce soit pour la primaire de la
doua tout que ce soit pour la primaire
du parti socialiste et de quelques
satellites on
se sont trompés sur toute la ligne
puisque avec leurs sondages ils ont
passé leur temps à nous répéter que ce
qui serait à l'arrivée ben on a bien vu
ce que ce que ça donnait et aujourd'hui
ils sont même pas là la décence de se
taire un petit peu et de laisser le
débat or le débat n'est pas ouvert la
problématique c'est que les gens il faut
qu'ils sentent l'utilité de leur faute
et et dans ce cadre là ça tombe bien que
ce soit là on ne trouve pas tout à fait
d'accord sur un point mais ce jour
d'étape moment on est d'accord
avec les verts et
donc les verts sont plus ouverts mais
est ce que est ce que vous entendez
beaucoup les verts dans les médias est
ce que ça danse en vous faire injure
dans les grands médias
est ce que vous entendez beaucoup le
parti communiste dans les grands médias
ce que vous entendez beaucoup le front
de gauche dans les grands médias
par contre on n'arrête pas d'entendre
les mêmes qui nous répète les mêmes
choses qui qui se base non pas sur des
projets politiques sur des projets de
développement économique et humain mais
qui se base sur des sondages qui nous
rabâchent sans arrêt et la politique se
fait au travers des sondages
et bien non la politique ce n'est pas ça
il est là on a des exemples flagrants
puisqu'ils se sont trompés sur toute la
ligne et par contre ça continue donc si
on veut intéresser les gens faut les
intéresser à leurs problèmes et pas
savoir ce qui représente tel sondage ou
qui est sous-représentée donc tous les
différents partis et les différents
courants ne sont pas assez représentées
médiatisée c'est votre avis aussi
mais pourquoi et là on se rejoint avec
avec luc miserait on en revient à cette
question de la proportionnelle notre
candidat à la présidentielle yannick
jadot a sorti son programme avec des
mesures extrêmement fortes notamment sur
la question démocratique puisque en
parle du vote obligatoire
nous proposons que l'assemblée nationale
soit désormais constitué de 400 députés
et élus à la proportionnelle de manière
à ce que lorsqu'une personne se déplace
pour aller voter
elles sachent que son vote aura un
impact direct sur la composition de
l'assemblée qui qui fera la loi ça c'est
extrêmement extrêmement important et oui
il ya une
un vrai problème d'accès d'accès aux
médias et de représentation lorsque vous
avez une assemblée départementale
je reviens aux 78 on est sur une chaîne
locale qui est complètement monocolore à
cause justement d'un mode de scrutin
électoral qui permet à une famille
politique qui fait 45% au premier tour
d'avoir 100 % des sièges
comment voulez vous que les françaises
et les français se disent je vais aller
voter ça va avoir un impact
alors que ce n'est pas vrai vous avez
derrière c'est cette union de la droite
qui a retenu 45 % des vols vous avez le
front national à 25% faisaient le parti
socialiste à 20% vous avez nous les
écologistes ont été à une dizaine de
pourcents bien souvent en alliance
d'ailleurs avec le front de gauche nous
n'avons aucun élu ça veut dire que 45%
des candidats et candidates obtiennent
100 % des sièges et bien cassé ça pour
que les gens se disent ça ça a du sens
d'aller voter je vais pas aller à la
paix je veux pas rester chez moi je vais
pas faire grève du vote parce que ça un
intéressant sur cazorla terminerait dire
que londres allait vraiment obligatoire
on pourrait envisager à partir de ce
moment là si on a fait émerger de
nouveaux droits d'envisager un nouveau
devoir
on ad'autres droit très important il
faut absolument redonner du pouvoir aux
citoyens et cela envoie alors il ya un
moyen extrêmement simple c'est de
flécher des budgets qui serait utilisé
pour des actions pour des projets
citoyens
est ce que propose notre projet
présidentiel yannick jadot
c'est ce qu'il appelle le 3 x 1 %
citoyens sur les bénéfices des grandes
entreprises agroalimentaires prélever 1
% pour des projets d'alimentation locale
1% sur les bénéfices des promoteurs
immobiliers pour de l'urbanisme local
pour de l'urbanisme citoyens des
économies d'énergie et un pour cent des
des bénéfices des publicitaires pour
faire émerger des médias locaux
associatifs pourquoi pas des chaînes
comme comme la vôtre
justement c'est là qu'on veut mais le
citoyen au coeur du dispositif
démocratique et c'est là qu'il a envie
d'aller voter
luc miserait un mot là-dessus des idées
de votre côté d'effectivement fléché du
budget pour développer le sentiment de
citoyenneté
oui puis elles en ont parlé des droits
déjà il faudrait que les droits soient
respectés par les pensées et ben je vais
vous le dire par exemple
très souvent il est commun de dire qu'
il ya peu de syndicalisation en france
mais paradoxalement on ne dit pas que
quelqu'un qui se déclare pour un
syndicat quel qu'il soit dans le privé
prend un exemple a toutes les chances de
de passer à la porte
qu' il ya une chasse aux sorcières qui a
été organisée pour empêcher légende
donc tout ce qui est de l'implication
citoyenne que ce soit dans le syndicat
dans le monde associatif est ce que les
gens sont si et dès que cela dans les
initiatives citoyennes qui était évoquée
dans l'engagement politique et citoyen
il ya des tas de gens qui souhaitent
s'engager pas forcément dans des partis
politiques d'ailleurs c'est une des
raisons majeures pour lesquelles on a
participé à hauteur de gauche et qu'on
souhaite qu'il se développe parce qu'on
y retrouve des gens de différentes
composantes mais aussi des citoyens qui
n'ont aucune appartenance politique et
donc c'est en multipliant ces
initiatives est effectivement qu'elle
débouche sur des perspectives ouvertes
aujourd'hui on a des gens qui ont tout
bloqué en nous disant que rien n'était
possible il va falloir quand même qu'ils
nous expliquent comment des banques qui
étaient menacés de faillite ont été
sauvés par les fonds de l'état et que
aujourd'hui il ya une telle dette va
falloir qu'on nous exprime la logique
moi je suis d'une autre génération à une
certaine époque on nous apprenait le
calcul faudrait pas faire un exercice de
calcul les mômes ils comprendraient rien
on déborde un petit peu du débat juste
avant de terminer un mot sur qui dit
obligatoire dit quoi sanctions pénalités
si jamais on y va quel serait votre ça
il faudra le il faudra leur alignement
débattre évidemment qui dit vote
obligatoire 10 derrière des règles à
respecter il ya un dernier point
extrêmement important qui peut permettre
de rendre obligatoire un vote de le
transformer en un droit seul en un droit
et un devoir c'est que les politiques
également soit irréprochable et là
encore à la proche des législatives et
des présidentielles
nous avons des propositions fortes qui
peuvent
remettre de la démocratie au coeur de
notre système c'est le non cumul des
mandats dans le temps et simultanées
évidemment deux mandats de parlementaire
par exemple semble être un maximum
acceptable de manière à ce qu'on ait une
rotation à ce qu'on voit pas toujours
les mêmes à la télé que ce soit pas
toujours les mêmes qui tiennent tout les
tous les pouvoirs et puis et puis
également on est aussi dans les yvelines
on a un président de département qui a
été condamné je pense que les gens ne se
déplacent pas non plus pour aller voter
pour des repris de justice et que à
partir du moment où on a une inscription
au casier judiciaire dans l'exercice de
ses fonctions on ne devrait plus être
éligible cette phrase merci david
j'étais un dernier mot luc miserait là
dessus ça va engager les politiques a
finalement s'adresser à tout le monde ce
vote obligatoire est ce que ça ne serait
pas une solution
en 30 secondes je je je je pense que vu
les difficultés qu'on rencontre je ne
suis pas sûr que c'est par des
contraintes aussi justifiée soit elle ce
qu'on peut dire que
comme on entend fréquemment et des gens
qui sont battus donc oui mais ceux à qui
ça s'adresse sont pas réceptifs à ça
sinon il aurait déjà changé d'opinion
donc je pense que c'est plus par la
conviction et les moyens qu'on donne
d'exercer une citoyenneté large dans
laquelle les partis politiques ont toute
leur place à jouer et par la conviction
il faut que ce soit un engagement
volontaire sous la contrainte
je pense pas que ce soit le meilleur
moyen il y en a des tas qui même s'il y
avait des amandiers bas ils paieraient
les amendes il râleraient encore plus
sur la peau contre la politique
donc je ne pense pas que ce soit la
bonne opportunité
merci merci à tous les deux c'est la fin
de ce 7 8 le débat à la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau débat
[Musique]